We are just a few days out for the 2024 parliamentary election
here in Korea.
There are 40 registered parties participating in the election.
I have compiled a series of videos
to let you know where the parties stand
on the issues. Over the next few days will be taking a deep dive.
I have compiled a series of videos for the 14 parties
that returned their election manifestos
to the National Elections Commission.
And I have translated their top 10 election pledges into English
for everybody today.
Let's take a look at the progressive camp.
The largest progressive party participating in this election
with six seats in Parliament
is the Green Justice Party.
They are an electoral alliance of the Green Party
and the Justice Party. Their election pledges include
applying the Labour Standard Act to workplaces
with under five workers, expanding the Ministry of women and family
to the Ministry of Gender Equality,
installing public care centers in all communities,
towns and villages,
eliminating tuition fees for students in national universities,
creating public medical universities and public hospitals,
enacting a comprehensive anti discrimination law,
enacting a Green New Deal in going carbon neutral by 2050,
guaranteeing the rights of the disabled
through the institutionalization,
the right of movement and other rights
and guaranteeing 1 million Green New homes.
The next party participating in the election is the Progressive Party.
they are in an electoral alliance with the centrist Democratic Party,
but they are competing in some district elections.
But Their candidates are tied to the Democratic Party
on national proportional representation lists.
Their election manifesto includes
a disillusion of the prosecutor's office,
introduction of a presidential runoff voting system,
believing debt of the common people,
increasing taxes on the ultra wealthy for wealth redistribution,
nationalizing essential energies, water,
electricity and gas. The opposition of the construction of new airports
and instead working on public railways,
guaranteeing housing by strengthening public rentals,
a four day 32 hour work week and enacting a anti discrimination law,
Equality Act in the Lifetime Partnership Law.
The third progressive party
participating in this national election is the Labour Party.
They have one district candidate in Ursan
and two candidates for proportional representation nationally.
They believe in things such as creating a citizens right to recall
lawmakers, getting rid of district elections
in favour of full
proportional representation for the National Assembly,
abolishing the requirements to establish political parties,
including the allowing of coalition parties
and regional political parties
and abolition of the National Security Act,
allowing teachers and public officials to join political parties
and engage in political activities.
Creating an economy centered around democracy,
ecology and care, combating the climate crisis,
unemployment crisis and care crisis,
increasing the corporate tax by at least 40%,
stopping the privatization of electricity and gas
and making sure labor rights,
jobs and living wages are guaranteed
through a major shift in the labor and employment policies.
The last progressive party participating is the farmer
and Fisherman's Party.
They support Universal basic income for farmers and fisherman.
They support establishing a National Food Sovereignty Committee.
They want 30% eco friendly agriculture.
They want to include farmers and fisheries
in the Disaster Compensation Act.
They want to increase housing for farmers and fishermen.
And they want a massive increase in care and government policies
dedicated to creating female farmers.
They also want to expand basic rights for easing of employment
permit system for migrant workers.
Join us next time when we discuss the Liberal camp.